First, what decisions need to be made?
The decision the sales manager needs to
make is, do we have enough capacity on
the support team to handle the support
tickets from the new customer?
And if not, how many people do we need
to add to the support team to reach
the desired capacity?
Second, what information do we
need to inform this decision?
We need to calculate the average number
of tickets per customer, per week.
We can then aggregate the average
number of tickets for
each customer, to get a total
average number of support tickets
that we predict will
be submitted per week.
Once we have this information, we need
to compare the predicted average number
of tickets with the current
capacity of the support staff.
Specifically, the average number of
tickets each team member can handle.
Lastly, we need to determine
the right analytical approach.
Let's use our methodology map
flow chart to help us determine
the types of analysis we should use to
provide the exact information needed
to inform the decision.
We want to predict the average
number of tickets per week
a new customer will submit.
Therefore, we're looking
to predict an outcome.
That was easy.